unser Wirtschaftsminister ist der
Meinung der Staat können nicht jede
gewinnerwachtung erfüllen oder
jeden Gewinnausfall ersetzen ja da hatte
100% Recht ich habe nur bei dieser
Wortmeldung des Wirtschaftsministers das
Gefühl dass der Fachkräftemangel
mittlerweile auch in der Bundesregierung
sitzt denn es geht nicht darum
Gewinnversprechen zu erfüllen durch den
Staat sondern es geht um die Existenz
unzähliger Betriebe in Deutschland wenn
sieben von zehn Betrieben bei einer
Umfrage zu Protokoll geben ihre
Wettbewerbsfähigkeit sei bei weiter
steigenden Energiepreisen akut gefährdet
dann befürchte ich eine schleichende die
Industrialisierung unseres Landes und
wenn unsere Betriebe nicht mehr
wettbewerbsfähig sind wenn sie nicht
mehr die notwendigen Innovationskraft
haben dann werden wir auch den
Sozialstaat nicht weiter festigen und
ausbauen können das ist meine